so the Creed movies are a really cool
mix of old school boxing movies mixed
with some serious feels it's a balance
that got started in the original Rocky
movies and all three Creed movies picked
up right where those left off while it's
always fun to watch them from start to
finish it's also pretty cool to check
out the BTS footage to see how the heck
they made these epic boxing flicks when
I found out that Adonis Creed AKA
Michael B Jordan was directing Creed 3.
I was like oh that's fire I mean it
seems like there's nothing he can't do
so I guess I shouldn't have been too
surprised right but still it's cool to
see him out there looking as swole as
we've ever seen him boxing his ever
loving heart out and then see clips of
him lining up shots watching playback
and stuff like that very impressive as a
Storyteller you really put a piece of
yourself into your films another
interesting reveal about Creed 3 is they
shot it on IMAX cameras Michael B
pointed out it's actually the first ever
sports movie to be filmed on them which
is tight and you can tell George hyped
about the tech because with it you can
see every bead of sweat on the fighters
and like the Ripple of their skin as
they get punched side note gross you can
also hear the sounds of their footsteps
and the ring better and you can even
experience the music in the theater more
basically IMAX tech means we all get to
take in the ring environment in ways we
wouldn't if it was shot on standard
camps of course the first two Creeds
weren't shot on IMAX and they still
managed to look pretty great too
speaking of those too when you check out
the BTS footage from Creed and from
Creed 2 you definitely see a lot of
Sylvester Stallone and why not the dude
created the rocky franchise and in turn
one of the most unforgettable characters
in cinema history no biggie but my man
could have just easily cashed his check
shown up to film his lines and said
adios but clearly Sly was heavily
invested in these projects and he was
more than willing to be the OG presence
on set it's pretty cool for starters
because he's not the star of the movies
like I can't imagine being first on the
call sheet for like a whole series of
movies and then having to be suddenly
the old dude playing like the third or
fourth lead so Props just alone for
making that transition with class check
out this footage of him stepping onto
the ringside area during the filming of
the first Creed the crowd of extras and
the crew and everybody is clearly
psyched that he's there and he seems
genuinely surprised by the reception the
dude has been a major star for like 50
years but he's out there smiling and
acting humble he even jogs along the
side of the ring and pretends to spar
not to belittle him because I'm sure he
could absolutely still beat me up but it
was pretty adorable he's also clearly an
influential presence on set he's been
living with these characters since the
mid-1970s and in this clip he talks a
little about the philosophy of the rocky
character he never expected to be a
champion he just wanted to go the
distance but it was also really cool to
see him literally in the ring showing
Michael and the other Fighters how to
box on camera from the looks of it it
seems like Stallone figured out exactly
how to be kind of The Godfather on set
providing insight and helping out
without stepping on toes because
obviously the directors Ryan coogler for
creed and Stephen cable Jr for creep 2
would want to be the ones fully in
charge so I'm sure they were nervous
about having such a legend on set
speaking of which Stephen cable Jr talks
about how nervous he was in meeting
Stallone for the first time I was scared
as hell man like Leo I mean we're
meeting Rambo For the First Time The
Studio sent him a car from the MGM lot
and it felt like he was heading to a
mafia meeting or something well I guess
the mafia and Salon do have a couple
things in common they're both Italian
and they both put out hits thank you
very much folks be sure to tip your
weight staff anyway after he got to
sly's house and they started chopping it
up all those nerves disappeared cable
said he got to geek out about film and
that made things suddenly so much easier
he also pointed out that at his core
Stallone is a filmmaker and way more
than just an actor like he wrote Rocky
one you know what I mean so it's like so
he's a writer technically they ended up
sitting in sly's screening room watching
fights on YouTube on his giant projector
it's nice when talented people get along
isn't it Gable also talked about how his
nerve disappeared quickly during his
first meeting with Michael B Jordan he
joked about how going into Jordan's home
and seeing him eating donuts made him
feel like he was basically at a buddy's
place although he did worry about
whether or not Michael would be able to
get in shape quickly enough which brings
me to another thing that kinda floored
me to be honest in Creed 3 I wanted to
know what a dinosaur's limits were so
you know how with each of these movies
Michael B looks more and more like a
freaking tank I mean the dude has
muscles I didn't even know existed and
yeah we do see that a lot with big
action Stars they work out with special
trainers have a crazy diet and lift
weights for like months non-stop but the
surprising part to me was that he said
that at this point that process is like
no biggie for him I'm like what you know
I think the training is something that
I'm used to by now honestly doing you
know the first film it would take normal
humans so much commitment effort and
sacrifice to look that jacked we'd all
be yeah that was the hardest thing we've
ever done right but when he was asked
about getting in shape Michael said that
at this point it's not that hard for him
between the first Creed and movies like
the Black Panther he's grown pretty used
to transforming his body so the
challenges are more about the character
work the emotional parts of the story
stuff like that he also felt a lot of
pressure with Creed 2 because sequels
are often not as good as the first one
but even if the pre-shoot training
wasn't something he was too stressed
about the grueling nature of the shoot
was no joke when you watch the BTS
footage you can see how intense and
actually straining the film was she
looks like hell to me if you're going
back to hell you might as well get used
to these guys had to be in legit great
shape just to even make the training and
fight scenes look real Michael was out
there running in the desert and like
slamming a real Sledgehammer into the
ground pulling tires with chains and the
other Fighters didn't exactly get to
fake their way through it either these
dudes were hitting the stuffing out of
punching bags and sweating like mad as
they sparred in the desert so even
though we all know that the fight scenes
are choreographed because you know it's
a movie and whatnot all the actors have
to be in incredible shape just to make
it look legit and this isn't anything
new Sly Stallone and Dolph Lundgren were
in serious shape when they filmed Rocky
IV and of course they were Arch enemies
[Applause]
so when I first saw some footage of
Stallone hanging with Dolph on set my
brain fried a little because that was
like seeing Tom and Jerry just chilling
like that's not supposed to happen right
but it's a fun reminder even some of the
most hardcore Rivals and enemies and
movies are just characters and most of
the time the actors get along great but
there was something kind of nice about
seeing Rocky Balboa and Ivan Drago not
only hanging out off camera but also
goofing around like old Buddies the two
RV have a really long history and their
epic battle in Rocky IV is one of the
all-time great fights this is a real
battle of wills and it's just very feral
and Savage Dolph even talks about how
special Rocky IV was pointing out that
there were probably lots of movies from
that year that made as much or more at
the box office as Rocky IV but probably
most people don't even remember those
movies Rocky IV had something special
speaking of giving the shoot something
special I thought it was really cool to
see a lot of clips of the actors and
director is kind of goofing around on
set when the cameras weren't rolling
although I guess technically the BTS
cameras were rolling don't at me anyway
it's easy to imagine that in movies that
are as serious and dramatic as the Creed
movies that The set would be like somber
and stuff but there were plenty of
examples of everybody having a great
time together even as they worked it's a
cool reminder that even when making a
serious and emotional movie everyone can
enjoy each other's company plus when
you're out fighting in the hot sun it's
probably nice to have people who can
make you laugh in between takes okay I'm
gonna go do like 1100 setups and 12 000
push-ups and see if my body looks at all
like Michael B Jordan's and maybe as a
reward I'll just watch Creed movies all
afternoon who knows where this day will
take me if you have any thoughts about
Creed BTS stuff hit up the comments
section